Wednesday Addams has gotten a makeover, and
some vocal fans aren't happy.
In their opinion, her name should be changed
to Mary Sue Addams instead.
With her deadpan wit, gothic wardrobe, and
affection for all things macabre, Wednesday
Addams is an outcast icon.
Popularized by Christina Ricci's portrayal
of the character in the Addams Family films
of the '90s, the teenage nightmare has recently
received a modern makeover.
Now played by Jenna Ortega in Netflix's Wednesday,
the character sports a fresh new fringe hairstyle,
as well as some new priorities compared to
her predecessors.
When Wednesday opens, Wednesday has just been
expelled from Nancy Reagan High School for
unleashing piranhas on the water polo team.
As a result, she enrolls at a new school called
Nevermore Academy.
While this Edgar Allan Poe-inspired school
for outcasts may seem more her speed, Wednesday
nevertheless insists on staying away from
the pack and only focusing on her writing,
cello playing, and solving a mystery that
plagues the academy grounds.
However, while Wednesday's many talents may
make for entertaining television, what some
are characterizing as a lack of realism has
soured certain viewers on Wednesday's character
in the show's early episodes.
For a self-described loner, Wednesday Addams
seems to participate in plenty of extracurriculars
in Wednesday.
Before entering the halls of Nevermore, Wednesday
is an accomplished cellist, author, and fencer.
She then continues to prove her talents in
each of these activities as the series progresses.
Certain viewers, however, have criticized
Wednesday's competency in her wide variety
of interests as presented at the show's outset,
describing her as an archetypical "Mary Sue."
In fiction, the "Mary Sue" archetype is a
main character who is incredibly well-liked
and competent — and without any noticeable
flaws.
In a thread they started on the Netflix subreddit
about the first three episodes of Wednesday,
one user wrote:
On the same thread, another redditor replied:
Another reddit user wrote that the degree
to which they found Wednesday to be more of
a caricature than a three-dimensional character
made the show hard to watch for them.
Additionally, people on Twitter have described
the character as a Mary Sue explicitly.
That said, most of these impressions seem
to be based on the start of the series, and
have elicited plenty of pushback against this
idea that Wednesday fits the so-called Mary
Sue archetype.
In response to criticism that Wednesday Addams
is a supposed Mary Sue at the start of Wednesday,
a number of users online have countered that
Wednesday becomes plenty three-dimensional
as the show continues.
"Where are your whiskers?"
"Ask again and you'll be down to eight lives."
For example, in a Reddit thread that criticized
Wednesday based on the first three episodes
of the new Netflix show, one user countered,
Another user similarly argued that Wednesday's
independence ultimately proves to be a character
flaw down the line.
On Twitter, people have also written that
Wednesday does not qualify as a Mary Sue.
As talented as Wednesday is, her character
still runs into conflict as Wednesday continues
past its opening few episodes.
Wednesday is constantly challenged, especially
when no one believes a fellow Nevermore Academy
student by the name of Rowan was murdered.
Her biggest hurdle, meanwhile, is her struggle
with empathy.
Wednesday's true failing, as it turns out,
is her inability to connect with those around her.
How she progresses through this struggle ultimately
becomes one of the show's focal points.
While initially the ultimate outsider, Wednesday
overcomes her internal struggle by accepting
people into her life by Season 1's end.